chaque défaite est unique chaque défaite
à son encontre histoire la défaite n'est
qu'un rite de passage vers une autre
aventure
[Musique]
chaque discours de défaite à sa
singularité qui est niée au niveau de la
défaite la défaite de jean luc mélenchon
n'est pas une vraie 17 c'est aussi une
victoire la défaite d'eric zemmour est
plus une déception une
catastrophe et la défaite de valérie
pécresse et ou
véritable séisme à partir du moment où
vous n'avez pas la même nature de fait
vous n'avez pas tout à fait les mêmes
tonalités la même sémantique le même
registre
oui c'est une déception
mais en même temps comment se cacher
tandis que je me préparais à entrer
dans cet événement dont je ne savais
rien me sont arrivées et bientôt
les échos de l'oyapock
frontière française
sur le brésil et puis ceux du maroni et
puis ceux de la martinique
et puis ceux de la guadeloupe
et puis
aussi
la fierté du travail accompli le pôle
première église qui nous n'y étions pas
que resterait-il
corps y en aurait un et nous avons
construit cette force
jean luc mélenchon est ton registre de
la reconnaissance qu'il est également
dans le registre des remerciements il
dit notamment niveau qu'en et
territoires d'outre-mer il fait
référence au mythe de sisyphe qui roule
son rocher c'est un moyen de dire où
nous ne décourageons pas la pierre
retombe en bas du ravin alors là remonte
nous savons
pour qui ne voteront jamais il ne faut
pas donner une voix à madame le pen
il ne faut pas donner une seule voix à
madame le pen
à dire cette répétition qui est la
meilleure des rhétoriques aussi que la
pole et on en parle et répétitions mais
pas sans poser question parce que
beaucoup ne voient pas aller chez marine
le pen mais ce n'est pas pour autant que
le tribord engagé ses électeurs à voter
pour un duel macro et il est aussi dans
l'orgie de la remobilisation c'est à
dire aussi du passage du témoin la lutte
continue
la lutte continue
alors bien sûr
les plus jeunes vont me dire eh bien on
n'y a encore pas arrivé
j'ai pas loin
fait mieux merci
il esquisse quand même un passage de
témoin en parlant de la jeunesse en
disant c'est à vous donc c'est à vous ça
veut dire que bon moi je suis un élément
dans une chaîne qui nous inscrit dans
l'histoire
est une femme qui pour le coup
n'avait plus d'autre enjeu que
descendront de dire sa vérité ce
résultat est évidemment une déception
personnelle et collective
j'assume en responsabilité toute ma part
dans cette défaite j'ai dû batailler sur
deux fronts entre le camp du président
sortant et contre celui des extrêmes ayé
en la circonstance du musée et battre la
droite républicaine
malgré la passion qui m'anime
malgré la qualité de notre projet je
n'ai pas réussi dans cette campagne
atrophiée et en l'absence de vrais
débats à me délivrer de cet étau et à
vous convaincre elle utilise la figure
des deux fronts entre moyen aussi de
dire que le combat était
particulièrement difficile elle dit sa
décision est une décision à titre
personnel c'est à dire que c'est madame
pas les greffes qui va voter mais elle
refuse d'engager homo partie voilà
pourquoi la droite et le centre solim
enracinée dans les territoires ne
doivent rien lâcher ne pas se diviser ne
pas renoncer à leur valeur est mené avec
détermination le combat des législatives
qui s'annoncent car je crois comme
jacques chirac
que tout dans l'âme de la france
dit non à l'extrémisme je veux très en
confiance emmanuel macron pour empêcher
l'arrivée au pouvoir de marine le pen et
le chaos qui en résulterait ceci pour
eve là aussi de s'inscrire tout certaine
façon dont une
généalogie historique donc à ces trois
éléments sur votre connaissance du fait
de remerciement elle est plus que dans
la remobilisation elle l'est plus dans
la reconstruction
[Musique]
jalome déçu c'était un homme ému c'était
un homme qui était confrontée pour la
première fois de son existence à ce que
constitue un échec politique
le fait que vous ayez été 2 millions à
soutenir un homme parti de rien qui
n'était pas un politicien montre que mon
message a été entendu je continuerai de
défendre la france et nos idées
il était finalement aux responsables
exclusif de secours qui à ses yeux
étaient des chevaux je n'ai pas su
convaincre assez de nos compatriotes
l'histoire dira et dira pourquoi nous ne
sommes pas parvenus alors qu'une
majorité de français partage nos
inquiétudes et nos espoirs
peut-être en raison de l'absence de
campagnes et de débats peut-être en
raison du traitement qui nous a été
réservé de la situation internationale
et peut-être aussi simplement par ma
faute j'en porte l'entière
responsabilité
je dois beaucoup de mes succès à mon
équipe je ne leur doit aucun de mes
échecs on voit bien que pour un candidat
comme eric zemmour qui est un candidat
nouveau il s'agit à la fois
de reconnaître l'échec de l'endosser sur
ses épaules et d'en décharger d'une
certaine manière son entourage ses
militants ses partisans et d'ouvrir une
perspective c'est à dire d'être en
mesure de mobiliser pour la suite je
suis déterminé à poursuivre le combat
avec tous ceux qui sont à mes côtés tous
ceux qui nous rejoindrons dans les
semaines à venir et je vous dirai très
vite la forme que prendra notre action
j'appelle mes électeurs à voter pour
marine le pen
certains auraient voulu que je négocie
ces quelques mots mais je ne suis pas un
marchand
[Musique]
vous retrouverez dans tous les discours
de défaite un certain nombre de
registres mauvais théorique qui sont les
registres ovo tomic de la reconnaissance
de la défaite
responsabilité que vous avez fait un
registre qui est celui de la
gratification vis-à-vis de mutants que
l'on part remercié et puis il faut bien
évidemment avoir aussi une une matière à
donner à ses militants pour leur donner
des raisons d'espérer et de revivre
l'aventuré militants telle aventure
politique
[Musique]